شهدت الاسواق المغربيه خلال الاشهر
الاخيره نقصا في اللحوم الحمراء وارتفاعها
في اسعارها بسبب تراجع العرض وارتفاع
اسعار العلف وتداعيات الجفاف وقد اوقفت
الحكومه استيفاء رسم لاستيراد على الابقار
المخصصه لانتاج اللحوم لضمان وفرتها
بالاسواق المحليه
ركود لا تخط
ئه من الزبائن واقبال ضعيف على الشراء
موجه ارتفاع الاسعار طالت اللحمه ايضا سعر
الكيلو جرام الواحد زاد الى نحو ثمانيه
دولارات بعد ان كان سته دولارات
75 درهم 80 درهم 70 درهم نصف كيلو
بالانتقال الى ضواحي مدينه الصخيرات تغني
صوره عن وصف حاله الجفاف التي تعانيها
البلاد في احدى مزارع انتاج اللحوم
التقينا بعبد الله الذي اشتكى من تراجع
العرض وارتفاع اثمان العلف والضرائب
المفروضه على استيراد الابقار
يعني كان طالبهم انهم يزولوها بس تكونوا
فعلوا ذلك
65 درهم 68 درهم الى تحدد 23% الى قاطرهم
ويزيد
في المغرب الذي يبلغ فيه استهلاك الفرد من
اللحوم الحمراء 17 كغم سنويا والانتاج 600
الف طن تساهم عوامل خارجيه ايضا في رفع
سعر اللحم محليا طلب خاصه
المحروقات التي ادت الى ارتفاع ايضا اسعار
النقل وهو ايضا من احد الاسباب الرئيسيه
ومن اجل ارتفاع الاسعار قررت الحكومه وقفه
تحصيل رسوم الاستيراد على الابقار المخصصه
لانتاج اللحوم والتي لا يتعدى وزنها
550 كيلو جرام
الموجهه الذبح
في هذه المرحله الاخيره بناء على يعني طلب
المتزايد على اللحوم الحمراء وفي اجراء ان
اخر قررت الحكومه
منعى ذبح الابقار التي يقل سنها عن اربع
سنوات بهدف الاستمرار في توفير ماده
الحليب ازمه اللحوم الحمراء بالمغرب اما
ان تتعمق اكثر خلال شهور القادمه ان استمر
الجفاف واما ان تخف وطاتها تدريجيا بتساقط
الامطار ما حلول فصل الشتاء المختار
العبلاوي الجزيره ضواحي الربط